at 9 55 a.m today the 7th of October
officers reported seeing a man armed
with a knife in the secure car park of
Ascot Drive police station off Ascot
Drive
during the incident a window was smashed
at the police station
armed officers were sent to the scene
and a police firearm was then discharged
the male's identity is currently unknown
but I can confirm he is a white man and
we are working to establish who he is
he sustained a gunshot injury an East
Midlands Ambulance Service were
requested to attend
officers administers first aid until
paramedics have attended the scene and
it was taken to hospital where he was
pronounced dead
no officers staff or other members of
public were injured during the incident
it is not believed to be linked to
counter-terrorism at this time however
inquiries are ongoing
as you can see according is in place an
ascot Drive is currently closed
and is likely to remain so while the
investigation continues
there were no evacuations of any
businesses or homes however a number of
local businesses located within the
Cordon took the decision to close and
Shoppers were asked to leave by those
who owned the stores
the independent office for police
conduct is now investigating the
incident following a referral from
Derbyshire constabulary
and the force will be cooperating fully
with the investigation
we are unable to make any further
comment at this time